one of the reasons I wrote the book is
people like how are you so optimistic
about America I'm like because you know
that line history doesn't repeat it
Rhymes yeah we've seen worse people who
had more control who were more
intelligent and more evil and willing to
go further they lost and they lost
relatively quickly and easily so given
that it's not at all ridiculous to
absurd to believe excuse me that the
same situation in a different context
can be replicated or at least narrowed
it to some extent
foreign
we're at the local Studio here in Miami
and I am glad to be with my good friend
Michael malis who has written a book
very apropos my friend the white pill uh
which I believe is all about Betty White
who played of course Rose nylon on The
Golden Girls in Miami so Betty White
it's your feeling it's actually more of
the case for white nationalism
did you ever see when she was I was only
able to thumb through it so far it was
half the white nationalism half Betty
White it's a very odd combination but I
get you there at the end you got to
start back in uh um Saint Olaf so so I
kid you not I mean when I first saw the
cover Whenever You released it maybe six
months ago as a tease or whatever I see
this covered the book is absolutely
beautiful by the way and I want to talk
about the publishing part of it but I
see this cover the white pill and
there's this sort of sitcomy the font
you guys to use reminds me of like a 70s
sitcom kind of thing and I'm looking at
these women here and then Betty White
I'm thinking this is a whole I honestly
thought for a moment it's a whole book
about well it actually so can we just
talk about The Golden Girls which I know
you're you're almost an expert at the
level that I am I think I'm more of an
expert you might be more yeah I think if
we had a Golden Girls trivia competition
I think I would wipe the floor with you
you have some of their clothes don't you
you wear matches negligation I have
Margaret Thatcher's dress I'm serious
yeah and I have to her bookcases in my
house which as an immigrant is such a
sign of like I've arrived uh and let me
tell you like do you do not want to know
how much costs to get to 10 foot tall
bookcases from London to Austin it's a
lot more expensive than the actual
bookcases themselves yeah well I want to
talk about Austin too because you have
fled New York yes you were you were a
big time New Yorker you were a Brooklyn
guy you did not want to leave but you
did but hold on First with the book yes
uh just some technical stuff so you you
self-publish this right this is a
self-published book but a hardcover
released on Amazon it's blowing up yes
you're taking out Mike Pence yeah I'm
like January 6th style according to no
no I'm actually doing it for real yeah
um oh that was good the I am delighted
that we are at a point in time when you
and I were kids yeah and people listen
this when they were kids if you put out
your own book your crackpot and in fact
yeah you're completely not bad right in
fact I have a little hobby sometimes
I'll get these old self-published books
from like 60s 70s and you read them and
you think there's gonna be some nuggets
in there and it's really really bad
um I have one book I just bought called
Belial the rebel Angel there's no
references to it online and it's the guy
who meets this angel in prison and tells
him about thanks to quantum physics all
races are the same it's just I'm making
it sound much more interesting than it
is but the fact that I can be
competitive with you know Mike Pence
Obama uh all these other
major household names when I'm nowhere
near their level in terms of name
recognition just speaks to how much
publishing has changed in recent years
and that in and of itself is a white
pill because for over a century if you
want to get again white pills what you
did there you said the title of the book
in a sense no but I mean I'm speaking to
the what the white pill is is an
expression of hope so for a century uh
you had if you want you couldn't have
the show 20 years ago I mean maybe you
could have it on PBS maybe you could
have it on you know like Fox maybe let's
say 30 years ago but in terms of
publishing you've got a a handful of
major Publishers which are shrinking
they're trying to buy each other out all
the time and if you don't get a book
through one of those you know all these
other outlets pretend you don't exist
now that is still the case the New York
Times will pretend I don't exist and
political pretend I don't exist sure but
in terms of me reaching an audience and
telling a message not only do I not have
to go through a gatekeeper I also have
to waste the year of my life because as
you know if you get a book deal today on
like January 1st 20 23 it's probably
going to come out January 1st 2025 at
the earliest whereas with me I had it
done on a Monday and you know to have it
out you know within a week or two so
that was one of the things that I could
not believe when I you know I did two
books and I could not believe you're I
was like wait a minute if I write these
things in a couple months the first one
I wrote basically in three months I was
like I still have to wait a year yeah
and then suddenly when they're after
that delay it's like well I've moved on
from some of those ideas at this point
you know I try to write something
Timeless but like things do move forward
and you're like man this is archaic yeah
and Publishers complain that like you
know we're consolidating and we're
losing cloud and what are we going to do
about this but there's not even a
hypothetical mechanism for them to turn
the ship around and that's a great thing
uh similarly in journalism wouldn't it
be a wonderful thing if the New York
Times wasn't the New York Times if the
New York Times was not in that position
to be the officiant and the dictator of
you know public opinion for a large
swath of the population I think it
certainly would be yeah do you think
it's fair to say that it's not anymore I
mean I think something does feel like
it's changing it's been changing for a
long time but I almost think we're on
the other side where it's like if you
were sitting next to somebody at a bar
and they were reading the New York Times
if that's still a thing that people do
is that a thing that people do probably
or at a coffee shop if you're at a
coffee shop and somebody's reading the
New York Times I would be looking at
them like man that is a that is an
ill-informed confused person like I
think that has now sort of gained more
momentum than the person reading the
time or you would think of this person
is posturing they want you to see yes
yes that I'm sitting here
yes yeah yeah so I think with a certain
segment of the population there were
there were polls taken last few years
and in terms of trust of corporate media
Outlets just like the New York Times and
with Independence and Republicans the
number has like collapsed and once you
lose trust it's really hard to regain it
someone's cheated on their spouse you're
never going to look at them the same way
again because you're always that person
has always been a cheater even if they
have learned their lesson are you really
ever going to be sure and when you have
these organizations that just have have
constant propaganda so on and so forth
but with the Democrats the ACT trustee
in corporate media has actually
increased over the last few years right
yes so we're seeing this bifurcation but
if the New York Times wants to be the
official house organ as you would put it
at the left that's fine you know people
have much more of an issue with CNN or
at least CNN until the recent heads were
rolling then they had them with MSNBC
yes Mada was was a leftist Chris Hayes
was a leftist they have their
leicester's point of view go nuts
speaker left this point of view fox has
their right wing point of view Tucker go
nuts you know Sean handy we know Sean is
going to say CNN like the New York Times
has this air of objectivity and
neutrality but when push comes to shove
they will always fall inside of hard
left and I think that disingenuousness
is what the issue people have with both
the times and formerly CNN decreasingly
so so it's kind of a beautiful thing
across Industries right now because not
only are you able to get this out
independently and it's selling
incredibly well that you were telling me
right before we started I mean basically
because it's hardcovered you can they
can't even catch up with the princess
yet which is I tried to buy an extra
copy this morning it was literally two
weeks yeah until you could even get it
so it's doing really well we happened to
be sitting in a studio of a tech company
that I started that you're huge on
Michael's malice.locals.com we've
started to actually build the things I
think there was this idea for the last
couple years that you know Republicans
conservatives anyone on the right
whatever hell we all are at this point
uh we were just going to complain about
everything but it does seem like it's
turning there were two models for this
right so back in the in the late 70s I
believe it was early 80s Roger Ailes was
trying to start Fox and they wanted him
to be like okay we want you to be
competitive with CNN and he goes I want
to beat CNN but the other model was for
a long time people I remember this in
the early 2000s people were like we need
to have a conservative Daily Show and I
don't think locals is the right-wing
version of anything it's not trying to
parallel something that left
unsuccessfully so I think the way to
succeed and I don't think this is
necessarily the right versus left is do
you want to ape you want to be like how
I met your father or do you want to do
something that's original that you can't
get elsewhere and by doing it in that
way I think that creates new audiences
and when you have freshness and
Innovation that's an apolitical thing
and historically that has been a
function of leftism leftism is very
highly correlated with uh Innovation
with Artistry and it's only in recent
years that you have organizations that
can in some sense be identified as
conservative or rightly or whatever you
want to call it that have been creating
things that are original or
um you know modeling culture is is that
the craziest cultural shift do you think
we've had that it because the lefties
were supposed to be the creative ones
that's generally how it always was the
openness right the conscientiousness
you're going to create great music and
art and stuff like that now they've
become the dogmatic ones and you have
suddenly conservatives
creating things this is this is like a
massive psychological shift I don't
think in modern history meaning let's
say post-civil War has there ever been
red states that are the centers of
culture right in our childhood right it
would be Boston yeah which is now kind
of not a thing Chicago was Major when we
were kids now it's not a thing at all in
terms of creating culture great food and
so on and so forth but it's not what
Chicago was when Oprah and Phil Donahue
were there right in New York and L.A now
Austin and Miami are both becoming in
their own way cultural hubs I can't
think of Seattle was a cultural Hub in
so in a smaller Way Portland Detroit
um none of these but now to have a red
state where you know Austin is is a blue
City very much so Miami I think has a
republican Governor if I'm not mistaken
uh Republican mayor and Governor
um this is historically in America
culture unprecedented and I don't know
what it means but I am looking forward
to being to already being the big fish
in the small town of Austin yeah so
let's talk about that because I haven't
had you on for a while I still lived in
that crazy LA and you still lived in
that crazy Brooklyn so we both made
Moves since we last sat down about a
year and a half ago
um I take it you're happier in Texas
than you were in New York I didn't
remember how I didn't realize how lonely
New York had gotten towards the end yeah
it was like Survivor one by one of my
friends I don't mean people I've seen at
parties just people that like talk to a
regular basis moved away they they you
know you're playing poker like I'm out
yeah unfold I have just like a couple of
friends left in New York the majority of
them moved to Austin and to be able to
have a social group is something that is
wonderful New Yorkers are told to lie
and I believe this my entire life which
is you know these people who move out in
New York oh they're weak they can't hack
it and at a certain point it does become
like Atlas Shrugged Iran's book it's
like why am I carrying this burden like
what what is my upside here so I could
stand up and say look how tough I am New
Yorker no one's ever going to perceive
me as tough well there was a time where
that had value right there was a time
when the toughness and the culture was
there but it just simply isn't there
anymore I went back over the summer I
hadn't been there for a whole year
because Tim Poole put up a billboard in
me in Times Square I'm like a person
right this is bucket list literally put
you up in the times where your face Tim
cast looking down at the dresses as is
my destiny and
I was so angered uh to see that all the
places because obviously a lot of places
I adore didn't survive covid you would
think after a year there'd be healing
like people would be returning you know
what I mean like I would say like a
quarter of the storefronts were
unoccupied there was not this enthusiasm
in the air
um there was really no place that I
wanted to go necessarily it is not
fertile soil to have a Renaissance
anymore and that is something that even
pre-giuliani I'd never experienced in my
lifetime New York's crime era people
don't realize it was an opportunity
because if you were like a poor artist
who can handle living in dangerous
streets you could still get an apartment
and you could still go there and create
and make a scene yeah and the rents are
too high for that and everything else is
too difficult you're not going to be a
cultural magnet as you were you know 23
or you know 30 years ago in the 70s when
you know the punk scene was so what do
you think happens to New York City
because to me it has not hit rock bottom
yet I agree the times that I've been
there in the last two years it's more
depressing each time there are no people
doing business that's what I always
notice even in Midtown so I've gone for
Gutfeld you know so fox is right in the
middle of Midtown it's supposed to be
people in suits that's what you used to
see groups of guys in suits going to
lunch and doing business now it's just
people in hoodies all walking alone
everyone looks like they're up to no
good and the whole place smells like
weed and I'm not against weed as a
general rule and I know you're certainly
not against making it illegal right but
it shouldn't the your business center
shouldn't smell like weed all day it's
kind of scary that having my face and
Times Square is in Rock Bottom I would
have thought this is as low as I get but
apparently the basement has a Cellar
yeah and the the crime and it's just
something that I remember as a kid you
know kind of in the background because I
was much younger but to have that kind
of sense of the thing that I think is
the worst part is there doesn't seem to
be any will or plan to turn it around
now if if mayor Adams was like let's try
this let's try that or governor kokel
was saying you know this is our plan to
kind of have a lot of faith in her but
they're not even identifying issues
they're just kind of being like oh
you're just making this up for
propaganda purpose New York is safer
than ever it's just like okay if people
don't feel safe that in and of itself is
a problem so why are they misperceiving
in your opinion uh this lack of safety
so a guy like you who strikes me you're
such a New Yorker like yes in the best
sense of that I mean that so you go to
Texas now you're in Austin which
obviously is a blue City in a red State
um culture shock or did you just kind of
just get there and you're good to go
well it's kind of cute because some
people come at me they're like you moved
to the San Francisco of Texas I'm like
yeah the key word here is of Texas this
is not needles on the street right uh
like complete Chessa Boudin district
attorney kind of situation it's still
very Texan uh in its own but there is
there's a pretty decent homeless problem
we had a referendum they cleaned them up
it's not like no no it's not like back
in L.A no they used to be like la like
the entire Street was tense I don't know
where they went
um I I don't really care at this point
but it I mean because you had it was
really really bad you couldn't I visited
during covet I was doing Rogan and I
wanted to go get ice cream and I'd take
an Uber a few blocks because the streets
were completely deserted and the only
people on the streets were like literal
junkies I'm like this is not a good uh
look for me this is not going to end
well for me but now it's it's it's just
absolutely I'm just very very happy the
fact that I can own a gun in my own home
uh is just just wonderfully reassuring
because in New York you know I have cool
stuff I put in Instagram sometimes if
someone breaks into my house I can't
defend myself or I'm going to jail
they'll be much more likely to prosecute
someone who defends their home with a
gun than someone who breaks into the
house now you know I if someone comes to
my someone comes to my house even if
they're my friend I can shoot them and
it's Texas and I'll have no
repercussions so come on over Dave if
they are coming for your Blanche Deborah
negligee they are gonna get a bullet in
their ass it covers it exactly covers
the perky bosom what is it about Austin
that keeps it blue in a red state so a
state that's pretty functional that's
making sense and everything else and
then and then there is this there's
artists there obviously it's just a
different thing what is the blue text
well I I think what is that yeah I think
conservatives always talk about like oh
these are the um policies and all these
democrat-run cities there are no
republican-run cities if you look at the
top 20 cities of the population I think
Miami is the only one with the
Republican mayor so cities are
historically run by democrats and
there's a lot of reasons one of the
biggest reasons is if you're living
shoulder to shoulder with people you
have to have this liberal probably more
classical liberal sense of like Live and
Let Live because you can't really be in
each other's business if you're just
kind of this close you have to kind of
make the sacrifice in terms of being a
busybody
um and some blue cities are obviously
run very differently than others there's
a reason San Francisco can afford to
have these massive rents you know as
Detroit you're selling houses for a
dollar or Baltimore it is another one or
New York versus LA there's different
metrics that go into it
um it's so it's not at all to me uh blue
in the sense that La was blue we're not
people aren't wearing masks they're not
having these stupid virtue signaling
lines and the windows of the stores and
I feel like Austin I think more than
Miami and I I I bet you'd agree with me
has become this kind of Beacon for
people who are refugees within America
like a lot more than Miami why more than
Miami because I'm seeing the beacon is
freaking bright over here there may not
be a perfect way to quantify it but I
feel like Austin has more scenes than
Miami does so we have like the Bitcoin
people the the
um we've got the Bitcoin people hold on
hold on people very defensive but we've
got here we've got a bigger stand-up
comedy seeing a field in New York we've
got a bigger podcast scene I think the
New York
um are we talking about Miami Miami
there's a biohacker community Whole
Foods started so there's a lot of white
people stuff uh thing happening in
Austin no but you don't have Whole Foods
culture you know what I mean like that
stuff why people like where you're just
trying to go to you know the spa and you
do the cold plunge and then you do rock
climbing all that stuff absolutely you
know I find anathema so I feel like like
that kind of thing is more and I think
Miami has more history than Austin
Miami's been a city for a lot longer as
a major city than Austin has so Austin
is in some ways finding its own
character now as opposed to Miami's has
always been like a party town right and
we're not a party town right I'm in The
Burbs it's very quiet exactly your dad
there's this I'm a dad there's lizards
it's all very pleasant you know when it
gets cold you know iguanas fall out of
the sky yeah they have like they go
unconscious and yeah yeah there was an
iguana you got problems it's not what's
the problem it's Iguana's got a problem
all right so let's talk about the book a
little bit so the white pill now before
we get into the specifics of the book I
just want to talk about the concept of
the white pill because over the last
couple months when I'm doing my show and
it's like everything they lie about
everything you know media lies about
everything the politicians lie we do all
the wef stuff over the last couple of
weeks oh yeah it's like there's lies
everywhere the steam seem to be
getting more and moronic like everything
seems to be so idiotic but I always try
to end my show with a white pill like
that there is hope yeah and and usually
I frame that around what's going on in
Florida and DeSantis you know from a
political perspective that there is a
place that is a citadel of Freedom as he
always says so first off did you always
is it built in you to have the the white
pill the idea that there is something
better on the other side that we can get
through all this stuff and you wanted to
find the white pill exactly sure I'll
I'll Define at the end this is one of my
favorite criticisms when people tell me
that oh you have too optimistic of a
view of Human Nature Michael malice
thanks people are genuinely kind and
nice yeah it doesn't see the dark side
ever the North Korea guy
um you you're the what the white pill is
is simply shorthand it's an expression
of Hope and as I Define it it is it's
possible that we the people who fight
for goodness will lose it's not possible
that we must lose and you in just in
yourself gave the white pill you can't
look at the WWEF people and all these
other villains in our culture and be
like I can't stop these guys they're
going to run the table at me these are
often clowns they're they're much more
akin to clowns than they are to Gods but
there's this belief among some people
especially among conservatives
conservatives take a lot you know my
famous expression is conservatives and
it's progressives and driving the speed
limit conservatives have taken from
progressivism this idea subconsciously
they'll never say it publicly or
explicitly that being a victim is a mark
of status right you talk about the
victim elliptics you know where like
where does a black lesbian compare it to
like a Native American and paraplegic
right it depends on the day depends
right but can service love talking about
how you know we're getting uh attacked
on Twitter you know I can't speak my
mind on Facebook at my work so on and so
forth and that's all well and good but
part of that often many conservatives
feel like well there's nothing we can do
it's it's it's it's America's done you
know we're going to be destroyed in a
couple years and my point is you call
yourself a patriot well we call yourself
a patriot yeah if you're a patriot and
you think Joe Biden or any person can
destroy America in two years take that
flag off of your profile pic because if
America is so weak that one
Administration especially the Biden
Administration can destroy this country
replicably I I I'm not even saying that
by himself as a Biden people I think not
only you're not a patriot I don't think
you're an impressive person because
that's just to me it's an absurdity this
is America like we are you know Reagan
is a major figure in this book and he
gave the speech you know I cite in the
book in 1964 advocating for Goldwater
right and we're sitting here in Miami
with a huge Cuban population and he was
recounting an anecdote of you know he
had two friends and one of them's
talking to his Cuban Refugee Brandon
goes you know you're you're uh you're so
lucky you could Escape here and the
Cuban guy goes to him goes I had
somewhere to escape yeah if it goes down
here there's nowhere for you to go this
is the last stand on Earth and it was
true then it's true now I I'm so glad
part of the reason I wrote this book
which is about the Soviet Union I was
born Soviet Union and I'm like okay how
bad was it and I couldn't be in the
position I am now if I had remained in
the Soviet Union or later became Ukraine
so one of the things we just got the
book this morning as I said so I was
only able to read a little bit but one
of the things you talk about in the book
is that people don't really realize how
bad it is until it's too late and often
will actually welcome in their
oppressors and I feel like we have a
very specific version of that right now
yeah one of the things that surprised me
to learn while writing this book is
after the Berlin Wall fell and Germany
were unified so the Stasi were the
secret police in East Germany and they
were much more they were different from
the KGB which is the Russian version
because they played mind games they had
something called zerzung which was
translates as corrosion disintegration
and their goal was to drive targets
insane so they would do things like
they'd break into your house and leave
your like socks on your pillow right and
then they do it tomorrow and they do the
day after and you have to sit there
you're like did I forget to do this but
then like I didn't forget to do this but
then why is someone break into my house
and putting my socks in my pillow why
are they stealing my watch or my wallet
and you start to go crazy and this was
by Design After the Berlin Wall fell
East Germany later became unified
reunified Germany they opened up the
Stasi files so you could go and look at
who's what did they know about you and
you could look at who spied on you and
who informed on you and this was an
enormous question for everyone who's
from East German do you want to know who
was spying on you and do you want to
know who turned you in and it's not like
someone down the street it was often
brother-in-law sister your best friend
since College had been recruited now we
think I thought at least while writing
this book it'd be like this Reuben's
taken in gun to your head and they're
like all right give us 10 names and you
give me up and I don't blame you you're
like all right malice you know Shapiro
Jordan Peterson it's Governor Sanders
yeah we're all conspiring together just
leaving my kids alone right what
actually happened is the size recruiter
said a lot of these people were just
born board we didn't have to put
pressure on them they came to us because
they wanted to feel important they
wanted to feel like they were doing the
right thing they wanted someone to just
actually listen to them we barely paid
them anything and when you hear this you
know speaking to me like having an IV of
human nature
people in America need to appreciate and
I think covet opened a lot of people's
eyes how eager the average person is to
be an informant on their neighbors it's
not like you think in the movies where
Tom Cruise has a gun to his head and
he's like ah and he's like fine I'll
I'll you know name names no no it's like
they knock on your door and they're like
hey I saw Dave and Malice you know
having a talk maybe they're up to
something you should go check them out
and now he feels like a big shot yeah
that's a uh did you never think I mean
because you are obviously uh fairly well
read and have been around the world when
when covid was happening and you know we
were hunting down people at stores for
not wearing masks which I always thought
was the funniest the crazy woman in The
Mask hunting down the guy for not
wearing a mask you'd think you'd be
running the other way but they were
always running to tackle them
um it's like it's like a zombie movie
no no no go away from this right it was
a reverse zombie movie something like
that it was like zombie Bizarro land but
but that sort of thing I mean when it
was unfolding and you were in Brooklyn
which you know so you're on top of
people quite literally right like you
literally have people right above you
and right below you did you think that
it was gonna unravel so quickly I I was
very surprised I was very surprised I
had this tweet which I got a lot of
pushback for and I stand by very much
where I said if you if because one of
the big questions uh that Humanity
always asks is how did Hitler come to
power and how did those atrocities were
allowed to happen because we got to make
sure whatever those steps were aren't
replicated in any other country or any
other population and this was always
like was there something uniquely about
the German people or something uniquely
about him was the economic conditions
was it the Weimar situation and what I I
think people just learned I tweeted out
I said you know if you replace the word
uh Jews with coronavirus suddenly the
behavior of the 1930s German population
becomes a lot clearer yeah how can you
say this the point is the point is if
you we saw no matter where you stand on
kovid when you send a vaccination you
saw how effectively the me media maybe
even correctly create an out group The
vitriol with which people were attacked
the Glee
I'm glad they're getting fired these
people should be driven from polite
Society they shouldn't be allowed to
leave their homes they shouldn't be
allowed to get jobs blah blah even after
it was clear that vaccination is not
going to prevent you from getting
covered it's only going to prevent the
severity of your illness so and by the
way that's even unclear I'm just trying
to steal as much as possible right so
I'm trying to look it from their
perspective even given all that the ex
the hatred and the lack of perception of
those who are in opposition as human and
also the idea that like you want me to
die so why should I care about you at
all when you saw that mass drop and you
saw how prevalent it was I think that
was very revelatory for a lot of people
and it was surprising to me as an
American because I thought America would
have a lot more pushback than it had but
that's just kind of information you have
to choose and go forward with so as a
guy that obviously is not for a lot of
laws to say the police correct yes you
know they come in with mandates and
shots and they're firing people and all
of this stuff and then it all turns out
in essence at least from my opinion to
be completely unwarranted I fortunately
was against all of it the entire time I
am not vax they will never inject this
stuff in me blah blah blah uh it can
interrupt yeah it's also different now
that you're a dad right because now your
kids are threatened it's uh very
different calculus so what do you think
about this Theory I've said this a
couple times on the show I think that
one of the reasons they went so deep on
uh vaxing the kids who were at no risk
right they were never at any risk was
not because of the kids it was because
they figured somehow they figured that
if you can get a parent to it's one
thing to do it to yourself right and
then have to deal with the repercussions
if there's a vaccine injury or something
else but once you can get a parent to do
it to their child if you now find out
the child has uh you know enlarged heart
or a series of other problems that are
now arising
your ability to deal with that reality
that you had something to do with it is
so shattering you can almost do anything
with that person at that point do you
think there's something there absolutely
and here's the other thing from their
perspective I I've never even heard a
counter argument to this really and and
people can feel free to yell at me all
they want social media the argument is
because we know the vaccine is limited
effects efficacy right so you're saying
this kid who can't get covid is going to
get boosters every an injection every
six months in perpetuity like that's
what you're positing and I don't
understand even a bad reason for that uh
there still is I'm not a covert expert
at all but I still have not seen any
argument for or against symptomless
transmission that seems to kind of be
swept under the rug and I think it's
very very Sinister when you have kind of
going after people's kids and also the
other thing is they have turned children
from the perception of parents as
vectors of disease so that's a mechanism
to kind of separate the kid from the
parent and some in some psychological
sense so I I I think all this stuff is
very Sinister but
and I want to hear if I could ask a
question I thought that all of these
mandates and vaccine passports were
never going away and the fact that they
receded at all in many of these cities
is something I was surprised about were
you
I'm not surprised that they went away in
the red States as really as DeSantis
well no but like in New York City yeah
yeah you have to have a vaccine to go to
a restaurant so I'm not surprised that
once things started once the narrative
shifted a little bit that the red States
really did the right thing because they
didn't all do the right thing you know
people think that the red States all did
the right thing immediately it's not the
case and even DeSantis by the way did
lock down here at the beginning but then
you know people want to get him on this
but it's like then he learned after two
weeks it was like no no no no more so
okay there's that
um on the blue cities I did think that
it was going to hold a little bit longer
than it did so that at least has been
nice but it's left the cities the the
rest of the residue of it I think has
left the cities with all sorts of
problems and all the good people left
right as you said all your friends they
left so they were most likely somewhat
functional members of society and now
they've brought their skills to Austin
and families but it's an intriguing
question and I don't have an answer as
to why I was wrong and why they did pull
back
um and also at the same time it's still
illegal for a foreigner to visit America
unless they're vaccinated they just got
extended they just extended so there is
a um incongruity here and well do you
think it's possibly that it's you can't
do everything at once so this was the
first cell though let's see how far we
can push it we now go you know we were
able to basically grade the pushback and
now we'll do it again sort of like in
Canada like you push back a certain
amount on the truckers you see how much
pushback there is and then of course
Trudeau is going to do something else in
a year but like that you can't you can't
just Ram through everything in one but
the thing is they had rammed it through
they had so why didn't they normalize
vaccine passports in restaurants because
that would be a very effective tool and
especially they have the app right so
now you have an app to see who's going
to which restaurant under what
conditions I'm shocked that that went
away at all you think maybe it was
because they were they were shocked in
terms of the population transfers like
the numbers are nuts the amount of
people that have left that blue station
and it's also the whole brain drain
thing right so this was a thing in
America in Europe and America in the 70s
and I think 60s where you had these
onerous tax income tax in European
countries I know this is an issue in
Britain and all the doctors and
engineers and other you know uh
established professionals they started
fleeing to America it's like why am I
paying 90 of my income when I got I have
a high skilled job I provide for my
family when I could do that much better
in the state so that is something that
has a historical precedent to it as well
so in that
both of us who pay attention to the
culture wars wary of state power all
that stuff that you know we got some of
this stuff wrong too I mean everybody
did and I always say I grant that the
first couple weeks I grant everybody the
leash this was the first time and this
was out of a textbook so even if you
know everything about oppression we all
got whacked out for those first couple
weeks
um
do you sense that it will all come back
or do you think that the pushback that
you're describing actually has now like
irreparably damaged the machine or
something like that I think we are
reaching it we're playing brinksmanship
because whatever you think of Biden
whatever you think of DeSantis Biden has
an enormous incentive to crack down on
Abbott and DeSantis and other Rogue
Republican Governors Abbott and DeSantis
and Christy know maybe to some extent
some other Republican Governors they are
playing to the base when it's like all
right I'm going to give the finger to
Washington and I don't know who's gonna
and we just saw with the Kevin McCarthy
thing where you had 20 Republicans who
are like I'm not voting for The
Establishment candidate come hell or
high water they folded after some
confession concessions were made but
that's still within the same party so I
don't and there is
explicit talk in Democratic circles that
you know the January 6th Republicans the
Republicans are on American and you know
want to destroy the Republican democracy
itself I would to God that that was true
um so I don't still got him out thank
you so much I don't know where the this
escalation goes but it's certainly a
direction that I am very enthusiastic
about right so you're enthusiastic
because basically if the states just all
went their separate way at this point if
the federal government was completely
broken at the knees you would be totally
fine with that right I would be giddy
would you yeah I basically would be at
this point I just see no way around it I
think there's I think the inherent
problem is that the blue States will not
stop encroaching on the red States but
if if Florida and Cali and Tennessee and
a couple other states were just like
we're out I don't even mean I don't mean
a Civil War I mean just like we're just
all of our resources we're just getting
everything out of the system
the blue States will not stop they're
not going to want anything from the blue
States but the blue States will keep
coming but this is something like this
is one of the major themes of the book
right so and we're dealing with like the
Soviet Union who I'm sorry to offend the
conservatives are much much worse than
the bite Administration let's let's have
some perspective um
they did not want to stop either but at
a certain point they did stop and they
didn't stop because they became nice
people they didn't stop because all of a
sudden they recognized the value of
human life or they regard the value of
markets there were steps that took place
before they had to stop and completely
lose that's the whole point of this book
it's like how did these people build
themselves up and then how were they
defeated relatively peacefully
um and a lot of that spoil the book but
to apply to American context is a
function of Will and a great example of
this is marijuana legalization right
marijuana is still illegal at the
federal level uh when you had different
states legalize it they legalized at the
state level and they said we're going to
open dispensaries and for a while even
in California these dispensaries were
being legally and understandably rated
by federal agents because they're like I
don't care what Sacramento says this is
illegal in the federal level you are
brazily breaking the law we can't have
this while Barack Obama was President
too it's not as if it was just under a
scary Republican president and at a
certain point they're like it was like
the cost of doing this outweigh the
benefits and even now drugs are
different legal I think Oregon just had
like almost complete drug
decriminalization
it's still on the federal level
completely legal at a certain point it's
like okay the costs of enforcing this I
don't mean just the financial cost you
know the political cost psychological
costs whatever costs are cultural costs
are too high and they just basically had
to give up
so that gives you hope relating that's
something you said earlier about how the
the Waf guys that maybe they're more
clownish I think that you said than than
god-like it's like so if we just keep
pushing that's what I was thinking all
week you know I was watching some of the
Al Gore you saw Al Gore ranting and
raving like a lunatic I was like this is
not a guy who's confident in his ideas
this is not a guy who's got a lot this
is like I mean he struck me as like Alex
Jones to Jason I don't even mean not to
put down Alex Jones I mean like the
level of like screaming in theater I was
like something doesn't seem right you
you don't have to act like that if
you're running the table Yeah if you go
to Vegas right right right right right
right and the dealer who's gonna win
yeah odds in his favor you don't see the
blackjack dealer yeah yeah the guy who's
turning over the table is the one
playing Blackjack the one who's in the
losing position
um so I think that we are in a very
hopeful time I think the number of
Americans who are aware of uh the gun
control is another great example yeah 20
years ago you'd have the gun control
people and then the gun rights people
and they'd be arguing and at a certain
point and I don't know what the turning
point was the gun rights people were
like we're not even having this argument
because you're not already in good faith
you say you don't want to take our guns
we know you do we understand why it's a
non-starter you every time there's a
tragedy which is absolute a tragedy
which we would love to be able to
prevent you use as an excuse to take my
weaponry and my abilities protect my
family from the best from the bad guys
it's like there's not a conversation to
be had so I think that kind of
understanding I think and it comes from
both sides I think from Blue States they
just think these Maga people completely
out to lunch mindless they're an occult
they love Trump there's nothing there's
nothing to talk to them about that to me
is is healthy I don't think political
discourse can work toward freedom I
think political discourse always works
like when the two parties come together
you have war and you have these massive
expansions in the state when have the
two parties come together to decrease to
increase freedoms and decrease the power
of government that's not a thing maybe I
after World War II when they strike
these things yeah yeah maybe they've
come together every now and they're
going to bomb the hell out of somebody
it makes us feel good for a few days
right right usually but not them
and those people grow up right
um so all right so let's bring it back
to the book for a second so the book
basically is about the fall of the
Soviet and the rise yeah and that yeah
and then afterwards the white pill is is
afterwards and now but there's a lot of
weird stuff going on in that part of the
world right now well that's true so one
of the points I make is people have this
you know I'm an anarchist as you know
and people both say anarchism utopian
and then condemn it for not providing
one Utopia is not possible but wins are
progress art I mean the sense progresses
I mean moving in the right direction and
we see them all the time and constantly
in just one example is the fact that
they folded on those um vaccine
passwords I don't think that's a net win
I mean it's a net loss it moved in the
wrong direction but the point is guns is
another example the fact that if you
look at Wikipedia uh the amount it used
to be almost impossible to get like a
shallow issue issue you know in
different states and now it's it's
become part of the constitution in many
different states uh the fact that you
have all these states brazenly defying
Washington drug legalizations is another
one whether you like it or not the fact
that you have States who are willing to
uh you know have markets that are in
defines the federal law that is a step
in the right direction so and I think
the
for a long time and this kind of Harkens
back to like the Rush Limbaugh era there
was this idea that's Republicans versus
Democrats and now I think if I talk to
most people and they say who do you
think is more of a pernicious influence
on American culture 50 Democratic
senators or 50
um uh Executives the New York Times
they're all going to say the New York
Times and they're going to be right so
the fact that you're identifying where
this toxicity and malevolence is coming
from uh you're you're shooting at the
wrong people and I'm saying that
figuratively please
yes we will make note of that yes
literally
um but it is weird right because you'd
think that more people at this point
well you're saying basically that enough
people recognize it and yet these things
never change their tactics right so I
always say it's like you guys the New
York Times mainstream media CNN it's
like you guys don't have to be good you
really don't but just don't be patently
horrible but they seem incapable of even
doing it that's the thing they're first
there there's an accusation that
conservatives have Echo Chambers there's
some truth to that but the amount of
echo chamberism on you know the people
who are the New York Times is just
through the roof right uh there's no
perception that anyone who is in the out
group can have any even not only just a
good idea but just simply valid
criticism look what they did to Elon
Musk they loved Elon Musk yeah right
yeah right he's saving the planet and
now he you know he's he's uh basically
Trump Jr somehow
um so there is this kind of increasing
siloization of American culture but
that's really bad because if I'm in
power and I want to maintain my power
and I see that there's this big part of
the population that is a threat to my
power even my power is illegitimate and
malevolent I still got to know who's
coming at me what are the metrics so on
and so forth and they're just talking in
circles and I remember in 2016 after
Trump won and this was a huge like wake
up moment for many people uh the the
head of times I think Dean banquet was
just saying like Okay we got to do
better like we missed the Mark here and
that kind of went out the window very
very quickly completely went out the
window give me the white pill on on the
tech situation because we okay so we are
here and again you're you're on locals
malice.locals.com I'm a professional uh
there are things being built Rumble is
building things there are Bitcoin I know
crypto is hurting right now but like
there are decentralization things hold
on crypto's not hard and crypto's cheap
right so crypto is cheap so it's
probably good but I meant herding in the
sort of like broad sense of it's not you
know bitcoin's not at 70 grand which is
sure a year ago
um but on the tech side it still does
feel like we got all this information
that the government literally is
colluding with big Tech to silence us
like quite literally there's evidence of
it it's all out there I don't think
these NPCs blew blue people I don't
think they care they don't care their
minds I think they're yeah but I mean I
don't think they're relevant like if so
this is an argument I have a lot with
people who are for democracy and I I
can't seem to get through them and it's
just very frustrating when you go to a
farm right the farmer's always going to
be out who would you rather have on your
side the farmer or the 100 cows then
it's not a numbers game you're making it
a numbers game because you've been
taught since you're a kid that the
numbers determine what happens but
that's completely false and one obvious
example was Obamacare the Democrats had
super majorities and so they had the
numbers in terms of politicians yeah but
the population was like 70 30 against
the 60s 40 against it they put it
through anyway so politicians use
democracy and the masses as a mechanism
to validate that which they wanted to do
anyway but if the populist support isn't
there they're still going to push ahead
they don't care that all they care about
is their power and their agenda so yes
there's a big percentage of population
who are functionally Mindless and I
don't think this is exclusive to Blue
States or blue people at all blue voters
at all but to me they're just largely
irrelevant I think what matters is are
you going to attract the quality minds
are you going to attract the people who
are innovators who are moving culture
forward I I if Elon Musk voted Democrat
Democrat Party Line but he was doing
what Matt taibi is not a right-winger
Glenn Greenwald is a hardcore Lefty yeah
so Jimmy Dore is another one I know if
there's beef with you and him but
whatever no no we said we settled it out
okay good that's not even publicly
probably I've never said it on air
before I just had my show is it great I
don't agree with him on a lot but I mean
when you have people who are honest and
have a left-wing perspective that's fine
yeah and and who are a threat to those
in power that's you know there's so much
talk about how journalism is speaking
truth to power and one of the things
this drives me crazy because
conservatives always say oh when I was a
kid journalists are honest no when you
were a kid you were a kid when you were
a kid you think no one has sex no one
does drugs no one drinks because you
don't see it because you're a kid so
you're going to be oblivious to all
these lies and machinations and
um misdirection but one of the things to
talk about in the book is they've been
at this for over a century and have the
receipts when the New York Times
literally New York Times was covering up
the starvation of the ukrainians and the
haldemore there's a great book called
buried by the times which talks about
how they obscured Hitler's assaults on
the Jews because they'll be validating
his view that Jews are separate race so
these we all I keep making this point
constantly and I hope people understand
it we all learned in high school about
yellow journalism right and how they led
us into the Spanish-American War during
William McKinley and there's a record
scratch and the journals are honest and
then like 20 years ago they became
dishonest it's the same people it's the
same thing for over a century yeah I'm
glad you said that because I think it's
I think people think about it a lot
somehow that the NBC Nightly News and
the ABC News and that it was all even
keeled and whatever but it was like it
couldn't have been it just couldn't have
been by every estimation of what we know
about how humans operate and I'm sorry
to all the Boomers listening to this but
Walter Cronkite was a lot closer to
Brian stelter than he is to you and your
life will be a lot easier and things
like make a lot more sense even the JFK
moment even especially especially the
JFK moment
um
but what about the fact that they still
are colluding to silence us so I get it
they're losing their there's a certain
set of people that are always going to
be for it the machine may be losing its
power to do things but it did things
that are direct assaults right yes uh
there's not a dispute the question is is
it are we in a better position that now
we can have the receipts and discuss it
and look at it or would so Thomas Soule
who you've had the privilege and I'm
very jealous that you got to talk to him
not going to lie
um he often talks about how people
understand touch this hand do you want
to touch this hand
maybe
um he often talks about how people often
don't appreciate the concept of
trade-offs because sometimes it's not
going to be like you know do I want to
uh uh Rolls Royce or do I want a garbage
truck sometimes it's do I want this
garbage truck or that garbage truck
right you have two bad choices so a lot
of the choice isn't between Utopia and
and hell it's like would you rather have
what we had 10 years ago when they could
have done all this stuff and you'd never
know about anything and everyone get
away with it scot-free or would you
rather have it now where not only do you
know who did what you have in writing
what they did and you could have a
conversation about it this isn't where I
want to be the second choice but in
terms of is this an improvement in the
right direction I think it's night and
day and Improvement the right direction
over it was before uh and and I think
the trajectory in this context is
wonderful because tech people many of
whom are completely apolitical do
understand that Corporate America I mean
the corporate press or government actors
are often a Iris to navigate around and
that they have their own pernicious
agenda all right so I want to finish
with a technical part of the pilling of
America yes so you people generally know
let's describe each pill for a second
okay okay so blue pill first let's talk
about this because another one drives me
crazy yeah people like oh there's too
many pills yeah okay you can understand
I like the clown pill completely I've
been big on the clown if you can
understand a traffic light which has
three if that's too much for you I'm
sorry I can't help you for everyone else
yes it's two sets of pills okay the red
pill and blue pill yeah the red pill is
the belief that that which is presented
as factual by the corporate press is in
reality a carefully constructed
narrative designed to keep some very
unpleasant people in power that's the
red pill thank you Morpheus okay yes
that's Morpheus yes the blue pill is the
view that the experts are generally good
people who sometimes make mistakes but
should be deferred to and listened to
and what we see in the media is by and
large factual and truthful and can be
relied upon even though sometimes they
make mistakes but they do their best to
correct those mistakes right okay the
black pill is it's a wrap it's done
America the west and or America is a
lost cause yeah we're gonna have some
small pictures along the way but given
whatever trajectory the person speaking
wants we can't turn the ship around
there's no hope in trying the white pill
is
it's not possible to look at the enemy
class and say we can't win against these
people and and when you put in those
terms to me it's almost ridiculous not
to be white pill right it's actually
very empowering right yes
one more thing the reason I wrote one of
the reason I wrote the book is people
like how are you so optimistic about
America I'm like because you know that
line history doesn't repeat it Rhymes
yeah we've seen worse people who had
more control who are more intelligent
and more evil and willing to go further
they lost and they lost relatively
quickly and easily so given that it's
not at all ridiculous to absurd to
believe excuse me that the same
situation in a different context can be
replicated or at least mirrored at some
extent so you basically asked my last
question so maybe I'll let you make up
your own question but I was going to
basically say so so for my audience
let's say that is largely red pilled
they they don't believe the Elite Class
anymore they don't believe the nonsense
they see what's you know approximate to
treat something like that you get red
pilled for a while and then what seems
to happen to a lot of people is you
still think you're losing a lot of the
way yes that happens and then it's right
so then that shifts them to the black
pill yeah so I think you just answered
the question but but what do you find is
the best way is that really it just to
show them that this Elite Class they're
not that good this isn't the best of the
best so don't stay in that black pill
situation for too long because you know
what else get to the white I think
conservatives are very bad at taking at
a celebrating a victory so one reason I
wrote this book is you know I was on a
conserved podcast and I'm like why
aren't you guys talking every five
minutes about how Reagan and Thatcher
were instrumental in ending the Cold War
which was the central foreign policy
issue for decades in this country and
now no even talks about it so I have to
write this book I'm like the New York
Times can tell that story why aren't you
talking about this all the time this was
such a great a major accomplishment that
freed half the world and made things so
much better for so many people and then
my brain's like you know hey you
you tell stories why did you tell that
story so that's what I did so basically
you did a homer I'm a guy like me right
that's right I'm a guy like me yeah and
that was it
you got anything else should I ask you
about the suit or corduroy in Miami I
mean what else anything else you want to
do here well I I want it it's like a 70s
book cover I did a 70s look for you yeah
no no I got it I just thought if you had
any other thoughts that you wanted to
share or might I have to say your hair
is looking fairly normal these days
you've had some odd choices over the
years I in all seriousness whenever I do
a show like this I regard it as an
opportunity to have fun because I think
if you do not and this is something
Reagan did very well if you do not have
this sense of Joy yeah uh and you know
Al Smith who was Democratic candidate 28
was called the happy warrior if you I
believe if you don't have this sense of
Joy you're not going to be able to get
people over to your side and for a long
time you know progressivism had every
actor every musician so and so forth
they're all the fun people and it's like
you can't fight a regime unless you
fight it with laughter and happiness and
smiles and this is Michael malis
speaking so I and I wish more people who
were doing appearances saw them as
opportunities to kind of you know put
put some clothes on that are kind of fun
and put on a show for people like you
and I both know that for so many people
in the audience like this is their only
chance to kind of have the experience of
speaking with people who have political
views that are similar to theirs or at
least have thought-provoking
conversations they don't have that in
their school or maybe in their town so
uh insofar as we can make them feel seen
and make them feel as part of a
community locals.com is one of them uh I
think that's just a great thing and I
think that's before social media we
didn't have that because you'd have that
one weird Anarchist in his high school
you know nobody else and now you can go
and have this kind of community with
others not just on locals there's me on
the internet itself and all of a sudden
you feel less like a weirdo and more
like an elite it's a good time for
anarchists yeah you can get on the
computer and talk to each other yeah
it's very exciting yes yeah
and you could put out a book and and put
the former Vice President of the United
States in his place it's the number one
book for over a month now on in
communism so if people are learning
about communism through me I think
that's only a good thing as we sit here
in Miami here's what we're going to do
yeah we're going to end this okay I will
go out with you because you've got some
friends in town yeah and I want to show
you that Miami is better than Austin
I want to show you that Florida is
better than Texas okay I want to show
you that the Golden Girl house is
actually in Los Angeles I know that was
very depressing for me
I know I know well they have the house
the exterior was on the Disney lot which
eventually burned down but the house
house itself it burnt down the Disney
lot burned down in like 95 or something
like Shady Pines yeah like Shady Pines
it was because of the s'mores you got it
yes sir I got it good to see you always
a pleasure Dave
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of mindless dribble check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell